- [Instructor] In response to
fears of a chocolate shortage,
farmers are looking to
a high-yielding variety
of cocoa tree.
Which was developed by Ecuadorian
agronomist Homero Castro.
So this was a bit strange
that we end a sentence,
and then we start a sentence with,
which was developed by Ecuadorian
agronomist Homero Castro.
Because this right by itself,
this isn't a sentence,
this isn't a sentence by itself.
This feels like this which is referring,
it's giving us more explanation
of this high-yielding
variety of cocoa tree.
So I definitely don't wanna separate it
as a separate sentence
so I'm gonna change it,
so I'm gonna scratch out no change.
So let's look at this choice, so this say,
farmers are looking to
a high-yielding variety
of cocoa tree comma,
which was developed by Ecuadorian
agronomist Homero Castro.
So this one feels quite good.
I would use a comma and just
go straight to the which,
so this one looks right.
Let's look at the other choices.
Farmers are looking to
a high-yielding variety
of cocoa tree, and that tree was developed
by Ecuadorian agronomist Homero Castro.
Well this is just unnecessarily wordy,
we're using the word tree
twice, so I don't like that one.
And this last choice is
just like the second choice,
but instead of a comma
we have a semicolon.
And the reason why I like a
comma more than a semicolon,
I imagine, I view a semicolon
as separating two clauses
that can almost stand on
themselves, and in fact,
sometimes they can stand on themselves,
but there's a semicolon to kind of show
that they are related.
While a comma is, for the most part,
separating clauses that can't stand,
the first one can stand
alone by themselves.
In response to fears of
a chocolate shortage,
farmers are looking to
a high-yielding variety
of cocoa tree.
That can stand by itself.
But the second clause has
trouble standing by itself,
in fact, it can't stand as a sentence,
which was developed by Ecuadorian
agronomist Homero Castro.
So I feel good about the
comma right over here.
No need to over-complicate things,
if the simpler tool works.